[Music]
all right welcome back
so this is going to be a pretty
interesting and fun lecture we are going
to derive the heat equation one of the
most important partial differential
equations in all of science and
engineering
uh for a generic 2d or 3d or even an
n-dimensional volume
v
so this is essentially you can think of
this as some uh object some mass uh that
is going to be you know hot on one side
cold on the other and we're going to
derive the equations for how heat energy
kind of flows through this volume uh in
in time
and i'm going to try at key locations in
this lecture to tell you kind of we're
going to make some simplifying
assumptions but i'm going to try to tell
you
at some places where those
simplifications will break down and
allow you to solve much more complicated
physics
okay and this is kind of the culmination
of you know us using vector calculus and
gauss's divergence theorem
uh and writing down physics as
conservation laws and this is going to
be you know a really powerful set of
equations
so
again this all starts with a very simple
intuitive kind of gut feeling of what
conservation of thermal energy looks
like inside of this control volume and
i'll just tell you this is called a
control
volume
and this is this is a make believe
volume you get to choose the control
volume i could have this control volume
uh here that i'm just defining with my
hands this is an imaginary control
volume we can analyze
or this control volume can be some piece
of equipment you know it could be the uh
you know a bunch of metal pieces that
are connected together and i can draw my
control volume around those pieces
and so the intuition of that we're going
to use to derive this partial
differential equation
is that the rate of change of heat
energy inside that volume
so the rate
of change
um
of heat energy
of total heat energy in time
this is exactly what we wrote down for
the 1d heat equation when we derived it
i'm just going to write it again the
rate of change of heat energy in time in
v
can only come from a few things
i can have heat flux through the
boundary i can have heat flux out of the
boundary
and i can have um kind of radiation
effects or heat generation effects
inside
so i can have uh heat energy flux
heat energy flux
through the boundary of the volume
through the
boundary
we're going to call that s
of our volume v
okay so i can have
and one way i sometimes think of this is
that this control volume could be a zoom
in maybe i've got some big you know
block of metal okay i've got some big
block of you know tungsten or something
that i'm working with
and i'm basically going to just zoom in
to a little
kind of uh a little patch
of that and i'm going to be like kind of
figuring out what is happening inside
this little volume what's happening when
it
transfers heat to its neighbors inside
this larger volume
and what we're going to write down here
is true for all volumes i can move this
volume around and this conservation is
still going to be true
okay so i just this is just an imaginary
volume and it could be a little piece of
a larger you know wing or or object that
you're analyzing or it could be the
entire object itself
okay
so we have that the total rate of change
of heat energy and the volume and time
can occur because of heat flux through
the boundaries heat energy can leave
through the boundaries
and i can also have
plus
kind of heat
either generated
or lost
inside
the volume
so for example if this is an exotic
material like maybe this is
has pieces of plutonium in it it might
be generating its own thermal energy at
places at points in space
or maybe i hit this with a blow torch at
some point and i cause you know heat
energy to be generated inside the volume
technically this is true
even if there is a fluid flow you know
even if i'm just drawing a control
volume around a fluid flow and that
fluid flow is bringing in hot material
and leaving out hot material this is
also true
um this this conservation is true you
know in a gas turbine and a jet engine
it's basically true that this is the
only way you can have the rate of change
of heat energy inside the volume
and that heat flux through the boundary
then would be convective some vector
field would be carrying heat energy out
convectively
today we're going to be talking mostly
about conduction where this is a piece
of solid butted up against another piece
of solid and so it's conductively
fluxing heat through its boundary but
but again we can relax all of these
assumptions
so this is in words now we want to write
this down in math just like we did
before
so again
the
heat energy in a little voxel a little
delta v
is given by
uh
c i believe this is the specific heat
times rho the density of the object
times u of x and t and i should probably
have specified really way earlier that
the thing i care about is u
of x and t this is the temperature
temperature
distribution this is the variable that
we are going to be solving for and
writing our partial differential
equation in terms of is the temperature
distribution inside this volume that's
what the heat equation is going to write
down
and so uh this
you know times dv
is going to be the amount of heat energy
in some little you know delta v
some little delta v piece
and if we integrate this up over the
entire volume that gives us the total
heat energy in this volume this is just
factual it doesn't matter if this is a
fluid flowing through the volume this is
still the amount of heat energy in that
volume okay
c times rho times the temperature
integrated over the volume
and we're saying that the rate of change
of this in time d dt of this and really
i should be much more careful and say
the
partial derivative with respect to time
of this quantity because it depends on
space and time now is equal to the heat
flux through the boundary
plus any sources or sinks that are
inside of that volume okay again um you
know crazy stuff could happen in here i
could have like a
nuclear blast happening that's
generating heat through you know
einstein's e equals m c squared and as
long as my control volume is large
enough this is still going to be true
okay
okay so
the heat flux through the boundary we
are going to define again just like we
did before there is going to be some
heat flux vector q
where q
is going to be
the gradient i believe the minus
gradient
of u and now this is a vector because
this is a vector gradient
and this is essentially a statement of
fourier's law of heat conduction that
the
heat flux this has energy
units of energy heat energy per time
is equal to the spatial derivative of
the velocity and sorry of the
temperature and so this temperature
distribution and outside of it outside
of this volume there are little q
vectors pointing in every which way
every you know every point in space has
a q vector that is telling me where is
the gradient of temperature where is
heat flowing from hot to cold
and at the boundary
if i have any q
dotted with the n direction that means
that there is heat flux uh you know
leaving the volume
and so the way we write this down is we
have
our heat flux is going to be this
q
of x and t
dotted into the normal direction
integrated up over the entire boundary
and i'm making this little surface
symbol we integrate the whole surface
the whole boundary of this domain
and so for a 3d volume this is a 2d
surface integral
of the heat flux dotted in the normal
direction
and to be consistent i need this to be
negative because actually um
heat flux goes from hot
to cold
and just like in the 1d heat equation
essentially if i have a positive heat
flux
if i have hot to cold to colder then
heat is fluxing in and i have a positive
uh
a positive
rate of change of my thermal energy and
so because this is minus gradient of u i
need a minus sign out front you can
really just check for yourself that the
signs work out i always spend about five
minutes doing this with my class
to confirm that this negative sign
belongs here and this negative sign
belongs here if you go back to my 1d
heat equation derivation i go carefully
through why these signs are correct just
take it as a given that the way we
define a heat flux vector q
means that
if this quantity is negative if i have
negative heat flux out of the out of the
domain
then that negative heat flux times this
negative uh gives me a positive here
sorry i think that was a little
confusing
a positive heat flux out of the boundary
is a negative rate of change of heat
energy inside the boundary that's the
easiest way to say it if i have a
positive heat flux dotted in the out of
the boundary direction if i have a
positive heat flux
leaving the domain
then this whole thing would be negative
which means that i am losing heat energy
inside that volume so if i'm fluxing out
of the heat energy out i'm losing the
total integral heat energy
and then finally this last term's
actually really easy we just call this a
function big q
of x and t it's defined everywhere in
the volume
and we just keep track of how much heat
is being added or lost at every point in
time
so at every point x at every point time
i just do a little accounting like is
there some atomic process or some
fission process or some you know weird
other process that's causing me to
generate or lose heat
inside of this volume and this is one of
the things i absolutely love
about thermodynamics and about partial
differential equations and about these
conservation laws
this conservation law is true for
relativistic systems if as long as
you're keeping careful track of energy
and mass
you know things do add up to be
conserved maybe you will have a rate of
change of mass but it's balanced by a
rate of change of energy for example in
this you know atomic bomb example
and so that's one of the things i really
love about this
good so we have a volume integral on the
left
then a surface integral and a volume
integral
and if you know me you know that i want
to get these all under the same volume
integral because then i can derive a
partial differential equation out
so that's what i'm going to do is we're
going to use gauss's theorem here so
we're going to essentially use
gauss's divergence theorem div
theorem
to turn this into a volume integral of
the divergence of this quantity inside
okay
and so i'm just going to rewrite this we
have
and i'm trying to decide if i want to
write this
inside i guess i'm going to do it like
this
so i have
d dt
of my volume integral of c rho u
of x
and t
dv
equals and now i'm going to use gauss's
divergence theorem this becomes minus
a volume integral
of the divergence of q
of x and t integrated over my volume so
i've turned this into a
volume integral by the divergence
theorem the divergence of the heat flux
plus the triple volume integral of q
x t
dv
okay so that's pretty cool now we have
everything under a volume integral and
what we can start doing is start moving
everything to the left hand side i can
bring my partial with respect to time
inside
and c and row are constants so i can you
know pop them out and move my partial in
so i'll have partial u and all of this
on the right
so let's do that
and maybe i'll switch colors here
so now what we end up having is a triple
volume integral triple volume
integral
of c
rho
partial u partial t
partial u partial t
plus
the divergence of my heat flux term the
divergence of my heat flux
minus any source terms q
dv
equals zero
so this is really really powerful we now
have everything under one expression and
of course we know
that this heat flux q is equal to minus
grad u
and so
how do i want to write this i think what
i want to do
is say
and there's probably some kappa here
some constant that i'm neglecting
so if i have
the divergence
of the gradient of a function u we know
we've seen this so many times now
this is the laplacian
of that function u so i can swap this
out with a minus a minus laplacian
okay so in fact i'm just going to do
that i'm going to say
this term here
is minus
laplacian
of u
and i'm going to use this the next time
i write this equation and i simplify
instead of writing this i'm just going
to write minus laplacian of u because we
know that that's true
okay now this is what i i love one of my
favorite steps in deriving partial
differential equations this is super
cool we got everything onto a volume
integral why did we want to do that okay
this is totally fine this is absolutely
correct this can handle all kinds of
weird physics
why did we try to get everything under a
volume integral
it's because
as long as all of these quantities are
continuously varying in space and time
so i can compute their derivatives
this is true
for all volumes v
and the only way that this triple
integral can equal zero for all volumes
v
is if the stuff inside the triple
integral equals zero everywhere because
i could shrink this volume down to a
tiny little infinitesimal element and
this stuff inside still has has to add
up to equal zero so because this is true
for all volumes
i can write down that the stuff inside
has to equal zero
and so essentially what i get is that um
you know c
rho
partial u partial t
equals
del squared u plus
q
okay like because everything here has to
equal zero so this has to be true
and i should just be careful here
there's a little uh
this is minus a kappa because there's a
little
kappa there this is minus kappa okay
there's some some uh
conduction rate some the
the material has some heat conduction
constant
and so this is a little kappa
and this is the heat equation in nd this
is the n-dimensional
heat equation n
dimensional heat
heat equation
with uh with forcing
and so a couple things i want to point
out here
this blue statement above is extremely
general this is true if i have a fluid
flow carrying heat through a turbine
it's true if i have a nuclear bomb going
off inside this control volume
all kinds of crazy stuff can be
happening i can be burning rocket fuel
and as long as my control volume is
large enough
to include those effects so that i'm not
kind of cutting off this nuclear bomb
with my control volume as long as it's a
big enough control volume
this is absolutely true and the integral
formulation would also be true
but
here's the key simplification i added
early
the heat energy flux through the
boundary
i assumed that the only heat flux was
purely conductive this is a
this is purely
conductive
heat transfer
now if you had and so that basically
means we're talking about a solid object
a boulder or an i-beam or a wing some
solid object where there's no fluid flow
moving mass around this is conductive
heat transfer so this
q dot n here means i am talking about a
solid heat equation in a solid
if i had a fluid flow and i wanted to
keep track of the heat equation in a gas
turbine engine
i would need to take how that vector
field is fluxing material out and i
would probably i guess have something i
hope i don't botch this
um
you know if i if i did have some vector
field
some big flow field f carrying my fluid
around
i guess i would have to take
this mass
times that fluid flow dotted in the n
direction and integrate that through the
surface
and i would get something when i did
gauss's theorem like the divergence of
this vector field times c rho u
um
you know integrated over my volume
something like that and this would
essentially give me the energy equation
for the fluid flow for the navy or
stokes equations if i have a thermal
fluid flow this could be written as the
energy equation that would complement
newt uh
the navy or stokes
momentum conservation equation so i have
mass conservation momentum conservation
which is navy or stokes and then i would
have the energy conservation of how
energy
heat energy is being carried through
that fluid flow
but again here because i'm dealing with
this q dot n we're only limiting
ourselves to conductive heat transfer
now i could have radiated heat transfer
if i wanted with the sourcing term also
i could have you know this thing
radiating energy kind of the sky's the
limit you can as long as you can imagine
the physics and you're careful about
keeping track of everything using
accounting
this basic procedure is going to work
for deriving your partial differential
equation and it can get a lot gnarlier i
mean this term is always going to be a
surface integral through the boundary of
the flux
and you're always going to use gauss's
theorem uh sometimes stokes's theorem
but usually gauss's theorem to turn this
into a volume integral
and if you can argue that you're you're
not near any shock waves or
discontinuities again this this atomic
bond probably is a discontinuity but if
you can argue that the your your fields
f and u are varying smoothly in space
and time
then this has to be true for all volumes
and you arrive at your partial
differential equation
so i just love uh pdes because when i
learned how to how to do this and i
didn't learn about this until
uh you know when i was a graduate
student so you know it was a while it
took me a while to learn about partial
differential equations
but it really is incredibly powerful you
can take some basic fact of nature mass
is conserved energy is concerned
momentum is conserved
and you can write it down in words as an
accounting problem this is just what has
to happen the only way heat energy
inside a volume can change is if heat
fluxes through the boundary or if
there's sources or sinks inside the
volume
and then using vector calculus and
gauss's theorem you can arrive
at your equations of motion
okay is there anything else i want to
show you um
i guess in the absence of this q term if
there's no external forcing if we just
take a simple object like a hot
piece of material but it's not you know
doing fission and i'm not hitting it
with a blow torch then i can kind of
divide by c row
and kill this q term
and i get partial u partial t
equals some positive constant
times del squared u
so this is the heat equation that you're
often used to seeing this is kind of the
simple form of the heat equation uh
when there's you know nothing fancy
going on
so in 2d
in 2d
this becomes u sub t equals alpha
squared
uh u x x plus u y y i just want to
remind you that the laplacian operator
in 2d is just the second partial with
respect to x plus the second partial
with respect to y
in 3d
this would be u t equals alpha squared
u x x plus u y y plus u z
z or z zz depending on where you're from
and of course you can do this in n
dimensions where now it's the sum of all
n partial derivatives with respect to
the the spatial variables
uh okay last thing i want to tell you
this is already getting to be pretty
heavy this is the heat equation
and again
it depending on my i need initial
conditions and boundary conditions to
actually solve uh for the distribution
in space and time i need to know what my
initial temperature was and what my
final
what my boundary conditions are kind of
what what is the boundary of this this
object that determines this heat flux
through the boundary
uh and if i look at the
infinite time limit or the steady state
limit where
the temperature distribution no longer
changes where it has reached an
equilibrium so in the equilibrium
or
steady state limit
we recover laplace's equation so these
uts equals zero
and i essentially have you know u x x uh
plus u y y equals zero
or in this case i have u x x plus u y y
plus u z z
equals zero
and in general i just have that the
laplacian of u
equals zero so laplace's equation for
the steady state or equilibrium
temperature distribution
okay that was a lot i hope that you have
taken away kind of the core message
that vector calculus is the language by
which we encode physical
conservation laws
we encode
physical conservation like mass momentum
energy heat energy
using these vector calculus
tools from vector calculus triple
integrals you know surface integrals
uh and things like gauss's theorem allow
us to convert our surface integrals to
volume integrals which allow us to get
everything under a common integral and
if that is true over all volumes it
allows us to derive a partial
differential equation
and these partial differential equations
are the language for how we describe
how
objects we care about change in space
and time okay
powerful stuff thank you